edit score at bitcoin is just basically
a chain of digital signatures that
really reflect the the coins path
through the the bitcoin ecosystem and
here i think it's actually conceptually
easier to think of bitcoins as uh
collective entries into a ledger
rather than as a as a physical coin
because if you think about it in a
ledger you have a record of transaction
histories which is what happens in
bitcoin
whereas with a physical coin um
it's more like memoryless there's no
history in a physical coin of where that
coin has really been in the past okay so
in this context you can think of a
transaction as just a digitally signed
uh declaration by one party of its
intent to transfer some bitcoins that
they possess to another set of parties
and when i say one party possesses a
certain number of bitcoins i really just
mean here that uh there's some previous
transaction on record that everybody's
agreed to in which uh the party now
transferring the bitcoins was was itself
the recipient of a previous transfer of
those bitcoins all right now i realize
it's a bit convoluted so maybe to help
better understand the mechanics of a
transaction i can do an example of what
would happen in the context of a of a of
an actual bitcoin transaction so let's
say we have a party and let's call her
um alice which is the
common name we use for for parties in in
cryptographic schemes and let's say she
wants to transfer uh some bitcoins to
bob okay and let's say she uh would like
has an intention of wanting to transfer
uh 50 uh bitcoins
uh bitcoins to bob okay
now
remember that anybody who transacts in
the bitcoin ecosystem is actually not
transacting under their real name or
their actual name but rather they are
known by a very specific identity a
pseudonym within the the bitcoin
ecosystem and that identity that
pseudonym is actually
that actually corresponds to a public
verification key for a digital signature
scheme so in this case uh let's say
alice's identity in the system is really
some some public verification key which
we'll call um
k of a so alice's verification key and
in the context of bob let's say his
public verification key is
some vk
sub b so these are keys that are used
within digital signature schemes and so
we can assume that alice has generated
this key at some point and that she made
it public
and that bob did the same thing and so
now they both have identities within the
system and these identities are just
sequences of numbers that correspond
to public keys for verification in the
context of a cryptographic digital
signature all right now remember that
these
values also correspond to private values
so each person who's got a public key
will have
a corresponding private key associated
with that public key and in this case
we'll call the the private key or the
secret key which is in fact a signing
key in this context uh sk of alice and
we'll say that that bob signing key is
some um sk of
bob okay
and they're gonna basically keep these
keys private now let's say that alice
herself has received uh in the past uh
three transactions of bitcoins from
other parties let's say she got uh 25 uh
bitcoins from from carol and we'll call
it carol uh vk of c to associate that
with her key let's say she got um i
don't know 20 uh
public or 20 bitcoins rather from uh
from david and let's say she got 20 more
uh bitcoins uh from
from ted okay so these are uh these
bitcoins correspond to different people
that provided alice with bitcoins in the
past and so as you can see alice now has
an aggregate of 65 which is 20 plus 20
plus 25 bitcoins and so as a result she
has a sufficient number to be able to uh
transfer 50 of those bitcoins to bob
okay
so to start off with a transaction from
alice to bob for 50 bitcoins will
contain information about these previous
transactions so each of these previous
transactions where alice received uh
some bitcoins uh these will have been
recorded in the bitcoin ecosystems
they're they're gonna be made public
just like every other transaction and so
what alice can actually do is she can
take some representation of these
transactions and include them as part of
the new transaction with bob basically
as a as an anchor point to say hey i
received these previous bitcoins and now
i'm going to transfer some portion of
these bitcoins uh to you bob okay
so um you know in this context actually
she does not need to include the full uh
transaction details in the actual
transaction record to bob what you can
instead do is take the transaction
details and apply a cryptographic hash
function
to them to get a series of digests for
each transaction so in this case let's
say she has a digest
that corresponds to the transaction
carol she'll have a digested corresponds
to the transaction from from david and
she'll have a digested corresponds to
the transaction from ted okay and she'll
basically include each of these digests
into the
transaction record and what these
treasures allow you to do or really
allow anyone to do for that matter is
they can verify the chain of ownership
of these bitcoins because they can
simply take
all the previous transaction records
which again are made public they can
apply cryptographic hash functions to
the in
to these different transaction records
and they can verify that these
cryptographic hashes when applied to
those transaction records provide you
back with these values d sub c d sub d
and d sub t and that in turn provides
you with some type of a cryptographic
guarantee because we're using
cryptographic hash functions we have a
cryptographic guarantee that that alice
was the ultimate recipient of these
transactions from these different
parties we have this this nice history
that we can record and then we can
essentially ascertain in this fashion
all right and because we're using
cryptographic hash functions we now have
some assurance that alice uh couldn't
have so easily cheated the system all
right so at this point in the
transaction and maybe i'll
kind of draw a line so you can you can
kind of see where the transaction
details are recorded so this point of
the transaction we have details about
alice's ownership of these 65 bitcoins
and she has enough information in that
transaction so that anybody can verify
that she possessed these coins all right
so you can think of this part of the
transaction really is representing
the input
the inputs of the transaction now in
addition to the input portion of the
transaction there's typically also
an output portion i'm going to put that
output portion up here but let me label
it
okay and so for starters in the output
portion she has to include or alice has
to include a list of recipients for her
bitcoins and since alice wants to let's
say transfer these bitcoins to bob she
has to specify um bob's identity with
the system which in fact as you
mentioned earlier was
bob's public key so we'll say that
she'll mention um
v sub k of b
okay and she also has to record and
mention
at this stage how many coins she wants
to transfer to bob and as we said
earlier we were going to assume that
alice wanted to transfer exactly 50 of
her bitcoins uh to bob okay so she's
going to specify the number 50. actually
in reality she'll specify another number
uh but it's going to represent 50
bitcoins for bob okay
now in order for alice to get back
change because she has 65 bitcoins kind
of coming in and she is only giving 50
back to bob what she might then do is
decide that she's going to specify 14
of those bitcoins to be returned uh back
to her in the form of
of change okay so
uh 14 of those bitcoins are going to be
reassigned back to uh alice's public key
all right and what alice will then do is
she's going to take all of this data
this this transaction is input in this
output and she's going to digitally sign
that data and she's going to use
her signing key
to digitally sign all this data like you
would with a digital signature and she's
going to append that signature
to the actual contents of the the
transaction record and that will
effectively bind alice's identity with
the transaction record itself okay and
the reason it's going to bind it is
we're using a digital signature scheme
and so anybody who possesses alice's
public key which again is made public
can validate that that only alice could
have created this block because only
alice in theory can come up with a
signature
that corresponds to her public key
because she's the only person who in
theory should possess the private
signing key corresponding to her public
key all right then all of this data will
actually be broadcast out
so this transaction data will then get
broadcast out to all the different peers
and the nodes
in the in the bitcoin network so
everybody in the bitcoin network will
basically know now that that
v k sub a is trying to send 50 bitcoins
to b c v k sub b okay now at this point
you may have noticed a slight
discrepancy here that um alice
um started off with 65 coins kind of on
the input side but on the output side
she only has 50 plus 14 or 64 coins that
are being accounted for okay so there's
this issue what happens with this one uh
one last remaining coin there's kind of
this one implicit coin hanging around
that has not been accounted for
and what we're going to do with that
coin is that coin is actually going to
be used as a transaction fee alice is
going to be
alice is basically saying that that this
one leftover coin should be provided as
a transaction fee to what's known as a
bitcoin
a bitcoin miner okay and a bitcoin miner
as i mentioned in a previous video is
basically a an entity in the bitcoin
system anybody can be a bitcoin miner
actually but it's a node in the bitcoin
network who engages really in the effort
to help with the the broader validation
of this transaction
so what do i mean by by broader
validation well if you think about it at
this point we've just used uh
cryptographic hashing and digital
signing to validate that alice at some
point possessed the the requisite
bitcoins in the system
and that she not only publicly announced
her intention to transfer some of his
bitcoins to bob but she digitally signed
that that public pronouncement if you
will as a result of which her public
verification key which is her identity
in the bitcoin system is now bound to
that transaction
but what bob doesn't know yet even
though he knows all these things and he
can validate them what bob doesn't know
yet is whether alice tried to let's say
previously sign or assign those exact
same coins to somebody else like maybe
there's another party
let's say um you know alice has a friend
named eve okay maybe alice decided she's
gonna send
these bitcoins not only to bob but also
he's going to try to send these same
bitcoins to eve and bob at this point
may not have the assurance that
alice has not tried to engage in these
types of shenanigans all right and so
the tricky part here is that even though
all the transactions we we've talked
about have been made public because
bitcoin requires all transactions to be
made public we still need a mechanism
and this has to be a decentralized
mechanism that does not require a a
trusted third party
per se we need a decentralized mechanism
for agreeing really on the order in
which transactions actually took place
so that we can resolve any disputes
about someone trying to double spend uh
their coins okay and it's that
that requirement that that time stamp
that decentralized timestamp if you will
uh which is where uh bitcoin miners play
a very important role in the bitcoin
ecosystem and i'll talk about um how
that works and how we we deal with
transaction timestamping in subsequent
videos